バーン！
あ～　あへ～　あ～
あ！゛～～
はい！というわけで、砲丸を4つ買いました。
今回は
このほうがん１つ・・・う゛っ
5kgあります。
バンッ！！
1つ5kgあるんで、これ4つで、20kg分あります☆
で、今回このほうがんを使って何をしようかといいますと。
今ちょっと友達が下にいるんですけど～も
このサイズで5kgってやばいんですよ
これを
なんか小さいものとかに詰めると
想像もしない物が
すごい重さかと感じることができるんで。
もしですよ！
もし、普段
絶対軽いっしょって物がめちゃくちゃ
重かったら
どういうリアクションをするのか？
やってみようと思います！
ピヨン↑ピヨン↓
なるべく小さいものを、できれば重く見せたいので
今回こちらを準備しました。
落ちるなよ！まじ落ちるなよ！落ちるなよ！（汗）
落ちる＠％＄＃”バイ
今回はこちらゴミ箱です　ﾄﾞﾔ
ゴミ箱の中にひとまず
ほうがんを入れとけば
まあ、たぶん普通のゴミ箱の100倍以上の
重さになると思います
う”～～～～う”え”～～～～～～
これやばいよお～
っていうわけで、今回この以上に重いゴミ箱をセットして
僕が鼻をかんでるんで
その、「ゴミを捨てたいからゴミ箱を持ってきて」
って後輩に言わせるんで
その後輩は
いつもはとても軽いであろうゴミ箱が
とんでもねぇ重さなったら
どういう反応するのか！？
後輩：え！？
純粋に気になるのでやってみようと思います！
では、いこう！
ピヨン↑ピヨン↓
はじめ：よっしー？
後輩：はーい？
はじめ：よっしーちょっと来てー
はじめ：あーお疲れ
後輩：お疲れっス
んあ〜///最近どうよ♡？
いや。。
就職先がデュエリストになりました（泣）
沈黙だお！気まずいお！
はじめ：ううん、いいんじゃない？
苦笑と鼻擤む音
後輩：え？
はじめ：あちょっとよっしー、ゴミ箱とって
後輩：はい
ん///
ん///ん//ん//
ん//
はじめ：良いリアクション頂きました
はじめ：ありがとうございます
はじめ：ありがとうございますｘ2
良い声だった/////////
後輩：あ！？お疲れ様です
はじめ：お疲れ様ッス
はじめ：ｱｽﾞｳｪ!!!!ﾁｮﾁｮｯﾄゴミ箱とってもらっていいっすか？
後輩：はい。
後輩：え？
はじめ：( ﾟ∀ﾟ)ｱﾊﾊ八八ﾉヽﾉヽﾉヽﾉ ＼ / ＼/ ＼
後輩：重～～～
はじめ：いまお？～
後輩：はい？～
はじめ：今何してんのぉ～？
はじめ：ちょっと来て～
後輩：はいよ～
後輩：どうした～？
はじめ：どう？最近
後輩：最近？～
後輩：ちょっとね～
後輩：やっぱ娘のね～夜泣きがね～
はじめ：あ、そうなの～
後輩：あるからね～
はじめ：ね～ちょっとゴミ箱とってもらっていい？
後輩：これ？
はじめ：それ！
後輩：あぁっ！
後輩：あぁっ！x2
後輩：あぁっ！x3
ううっっっ…(;´･ω･)
はじめ＆後輩：けいすけ～
後輩：失礼しま～す
はじめ：よっ！けいすけ
はじめ：どう最近？
はじめ：まじか！？
はじめ：ゴミ箱取ってもらっていい？
後輩：はい。
ゴミ箱：ゴロゴロォォォォォ
はじめ：うおおおおおおおお
ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓
はじめが走るぜ☆ハシルズゥエエエエエエエエ
ペぺぺぺン☆
はじめ：ゴミ箱動かしてもらっていい？
まさき：え！？ちょっとまって～～～～
はじめ　あハハハハハあああーー！！
まさき：えへ/////
はじめ：はい、っていうのがやりたかっただけ～
まさき：え！？何入ってんの？これぇ～～